i want to create a baseline using the 12
tone technique drum thing and then a toy
piano
[Music]
slightly off i like it that way what are
your impressions of this type of video
it's kind of like uh intermission music
inner mysteries yeah
it just sounds like some dude is like in
this bedroom just kind of like jamming
and dancing like yeah yeah yeah i got
something going on
you know i don't know okay you can look
at the you can look at the camera
there's nothing bad in there
no i don't i don't want myself today i'm
just going to take the whole day
off
first of all i want to spend some time
listening to this playlist popcorn loops
and the art of sampling and glitch fati
thank you so much something that is in
common between all the songs is that
they have beats they are relatively
similar tempe
and a lot of sampled material is used
so i'm listening now to mum i'm nine
today i really like the
the tapping sounds
this is flying lotus tiny tortures
140 something
there's this
sound
it almost sounds like pecking on wood
that is very
satisfying by the way this was a gift
from meze mezz audio thank you very much
i use headphones a lot i have a
different pair actually this i bought
on my own
to use with my keyboard
so i haven't been using these for that
long but
so far
i will say that i prefer listening to
music with these as opposed to
practicing or doing something on the
keyboard and i think it's because the
best way i can describe it is that these
headphones sound
really good and they feel really good
and it's very pleasurable to listen to
music
with these on especially this playlist
where a lot of these beats have these
detailed sounds that are just enjoyable
to feel with headphones on but when i'm
practicing i i just want things to be
neutral these kind of make everything
sound
glossy and polished these
just sound
plain
mine sign
i think that's how you say mine sign
fifth dim
samyam
flotation device
[Music]
this is one one two
[Music]
vo
that's very pretty
very pretty
okay so these are all
these are chill chill tracks
i'm into it i think i want to create a
beat that loops around that loops around
definitely loops around that is chill
but with a different harmonic language i
notice a lot of jazz chords and a lot of
stationary and static static chords but
not always
let's start an empty project i know how
to do that yes percussion coconut grove
no no no no
no
i mean it doesn't sound great but it
doesn't sound bad and you could
really tweak it
wow
wow
let's change the tempo
alright so i think i have something
just simple
clacky
great part two i have the classic uk
hip-hop
i'm just using the patches within logic
i'm not gonna get fancy here
what's the difference
oh i like that
so we need this
definitely need that something like
yeah sure that's what i heard
copy paste paste paste paste
part three and so now we have fizzy
beats
yeah i like this sound a rhythm like
that
that that's
fine
[Music]
space okay so now we have atlanta or
this one
on the offbeats
[Music]
okay so i'm playing this on time but
there's a
delay but we can quantize this i just
learned how to do that so we don't need
a practice
we don't need to practice now
[Music]
progress so i'm just going off of what
i've been listening to
i'm gonna take a break this
is a bathroom rug that i put on top of
the piano bench and it has changed my
life
i don't know
toy piano
[Music]
slightly off
i like it that way now is the fun part i
want to create a baseline
using the 12 tone technique so basically
i won't repeat a pitch until i've used
all 12 chromatic pitches a a flat
e d sharp
[Music]
so i have a baseline written out 36
notes so 12 times 3.
so we're using synth ebase
it's a little
laggy here
oh shoot i messed up
oh i messed up at the same spot
just one line come on
[Music]
there we go
ish i just looked on youtube um
how to create this vintage piano sound i
saw a video that said download this
thing
and i set it so that it has a little bit
of wear
dust and it's slightly detuned
paste now it sounds like this
[Music]
12-tone music all right great so i want
to add another piano part here
this one okay so this is
basically two tritones
interlocked by a semitone so first
tritone
and then another tritone
you can probably name this
something else but
that's how i came up with it so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
i think i want to add a second part to
it but i'm going to
just sit on it think about it but for
now this is what the track sounds like
i'm going to put it so that you can hear
it without hearing it through
monitors
and
let me know what you think
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
do
[Music]
do
[Music]
i don't know what i did but i created
this
sound
and it got me thinking maybe there's a
way that i could create
a beat like
thing just on the keyboard
[Music]
[Music]
you